have we met no no I'm a complete and
total stranger
good luck up there remember to say I do
right Happy New Year everybody we
finally got confirmation that Don Allen
is coming back to the flash season four
she's already filmed her next episode so
I'll explain what the schedule is
because I think it might have something
to do with what is traditionally their
two-part episode that they do in the
second part of the season like they did
the gorilla City episode last year that
was two episodes the trial of the flash
the return of Don Allen I think will be
heralding something that will be paid
off during that two-part episode there's
a new round of the flash ring giveaway
to mark the occasion and we have God
speed stuff to talk about but that's
unrelated to the Don Allen stuff so I'll
do Don Allen first because that's been
confirmed so Don Allen the actresses
name is Jessica Parker Kennedy some of
you may have known her from black sails
she played a pretty big character on
that TV show so when she showed up on
the flash people were like wow this is a
relatively big actress playing what the
producers said was a mystery girl so she
said when she went in to audition for
the role or the producers actually
pitched her the role she didn't have to
audition for it they just had to meet
with her about it they pitched her the
whole idea for this special meeting that
she had with Barry in the way that they
pitched it implied that it was this huge
payoff which is why I don't think that
she's Jenny aughh nuts because after the
episode aired there were a ton of people
that were like maybe it's his
granddaughter but instead of being like
a bart allen twist it's someone from the
very distant future is Jenny aughh nuts
in his excess so just a different female
speedster but the same idea is more of a
Bart Allen type character somebody from
the far future that's related to Barry
the reason why I don't think that's the
case is is because it requires a couple
more jumps through hoops and it ties in
Supergirl stuff and I think it's more
relevant to the Flash's storyline I
don't think it has anything to do with
what's going on on Supergirl this season
the simplest explanation is is that she
is so flabbergasted and excited to meet
Barry like she idolizes him because it's
her father if you're not a big comic
book reader the reason why it's such a
big deal that she meet him is is because
Allen died during crisis on Infinite
Earths before she grew up so she and her
twin brother dawn and Dawn Allen never
knew their father Barry Allen growing up
which is why it would be such a huge
deal for her to come back to watch him
get married oh my god the person that I
grew up hearing about my hero
my father this epic speedster this
person that I've loved my whole life but
never had the chance to meet is standing
right in front of me so when the actress
says that the producers pitched her that
it was gonna be this big payoff that she
meet Barry in this scene it just sounds
like that's what's going on they're
building towards that sort of reveal
like oh wow this is why she came back
but the good news is is that she said
that before this interview posted which
was a couple weeks ago she had already
filmed her second appearance in most of
the answers that we need to understand
who she is and what she's doing
we'll be in that next appearance and
here's what happened is is right around
the time this interview posted they were
filming episode 13 danielle panabaker
revealed that right before everybody
broke for the Christmas holiday they
were filming episode 14 last season
episodes 13 and 14 were the two-part
episode now they might change which two
episodes are the two parters this season
so it might be like 12 and 13 instead of
13 and 14 whatever but if she's already
filmed that second appearance then it's
happened sometime between episode 10 in
episode 14 probably closer to that
two-parter but here the next couple of
episode titles so this game gives you an
idea for what the action is going to be
I should actually probably do a separate
video for this because there's a lot of
information that just dropped so episode
10 obviously trial the flash we know
about that big comic book arc episode 11
is called the elongated Knight Rises as
in the Dark Knight Rises episode 12
Honey I Shrunk team flash everybody
remembers Honey I Shrunk the Kids
episode 13 is called True Colors as in
show your true colors in episode 15 we
don't know what episode 14 is called but
episode 15 is called enter flash time
which is probably a Hypertime easter egg
if your big grant Morrison Mark Waid ban
is a really complex concept so if it
turns out that they are doing Hypertime
related stuff for the episodes then I'll
do more videos about it but right now
there's no confirmation we just have the
episode
titles such as all signs point to dawn
Allen coming back and have something to
do with the Future storyline they might
flash-forward because she might be from
that post-apocalyptic timeline the sari
is from on legends of tomorrow because
remember she's from about 25 years in
the future which makes sense because
this actress looks like she's in her
mid-20s so it makes sense that if iris
got pregnant in the next year or two
she's born 25 years later boom she comes
back in time and meets her father Barry
Allen but again no ideas if this is
gonna crossover with the other shows
there have been Easter eggs for each of
the shows but the only real big
crossovers is stuff like crisis when
they literally crossover all the actors
it's just that in this alternate future
that Zahra is from metahumans have been
outlawed in the future of the flash like
in the time of the reverse-flash in the
25th century there's no more speed force
so we'll just have to wait and see to
get some more information so don't go
too crazy with your theory crafting
right now all we know is that she's
probably dawn Allen and we're gonna see
her again relatively soon like sometime
by February but the other cool thing
that's happening later this week in
flash TV territory is that they're doing
the TCAs last year around this time at
that event they confirmed that everybody
was renewed for another season so we
might find out which shows are coming
back I'm assuming that they're all
getting renewed but we'll find out in a
couple days
but moving over into godspeed territory
if you haven't been keeping up they just
brought him back into the comics he
hasn't really got anywhere he's been
chilling in iron Heights this whole time
with a suppression collar on to suppress
his Speed Force abilities but he just
became a member of the Rogues now back
during the new 52 that Daniel West
reverse-flash was part of the Suicide
Squad so it's not a new idea that the
reverse-flash would be a member of one
of the evil team ups but technically god
speed isn't the reverse-flash you just
call him an evil speedster because Mina
is kind of like the new reverse flash
because the reverse flash typically
harnesses the negative Speed Force and
she's the only one that possesses that
right now but Captain Cold is sort of
ruling from the bottom he literally has
this underground network underneath iron
Heights prison where he's living like a
king while pretending that he's still
inside his self so they're just gearing
up for
big flash war in the comics in there
actually is an event called flash war
that's coming up is gonna start in
February so I'll do videos for that so
it'll actually be pretty cool so it's
actually a really good time to get into
flash comics if you're not a big comic
book reader but don't worry I'll be
doing videos for all that stuff but like
I said there's a new round of that
blasts ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and just
share this video using any of those
YouTube tools on the watch page while
you wait for everything click here for
that other flash trailer I just posted
and click here for brand new Black
Panthers thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome
happy new year